hello everyone and welcome to another
very interesting game from the pogchamp
championship it's the quarterfinals and
it's sebastian for swedish streamer
better known as forsen vs. Albert Jenga
better known as box box so forsen from
the from the hearthstone and Starcraft
community against box box who is well
known in the League of Legends community
especially for his for his expertise in
ribbon and several years ago when I was
playing League myself I did enjoy a lot
of Albert's videos and was really always
very impressed how he how he handled the
ribbon so I'm very glad to check out the
one on one of his games and also I would
just like to mention that a jugar
released another chest video and this
time it's a bit different because the
lyrics were written by uh nigiri so the
link to the video will be in the
description below first thing you'll see
do check it out and now getting onto the
game box box opens with E 4 and we have
E 5 and this is a very interesting game
because it features something that
always happens in beginners games I'm
not talking about blunders I'm talking
about very specific well you'll see what
I'm talking about we have E 5 and 9th to
c3 now Albert goes for the Vienna game
we have Bishop to c5 and also known as
the Anderson defense and now g3 he
prepares to fianchetto his a light
square bishop which is a bit of an
unusual move order but if it works for
him why not
we have Knight to f6 developing
preparing the castle and the Box box
goes for h3 he takes away the g4 Square
from and blacks pieces in the future we
have c6 and here there is one game where
Bishop to g2 was played however here we
have Knight G te to first and it is
already as a move v that we have a
completely new game so far I think all
of our games from pock champs were a new
game as of move 5 and here of course as
white allowed that black strikes in the
center so d5 grabbing more space
challenging the e4 pawn but also maybe
d4 will be an idea so e captor Sundy 5c
captures and e5 and the bishop to g2 now
developing the LightSquared bishop
preparing the castle putting pressure on
the d5 pawn and so on so black advances
it to d4 kicks away the white knight
from c3 Knights the e4 and here we have
a captures so captures captures and we
have castles by black and now white
black has an extremely strong center f5
will be an idea in the future and the
black is somewhat better here so white
castles and now box box offers the h3
pawn here which is very interesting
however by going after the h3 pawn you
leave your b7 pawn defenseless so here
black calculates well he goes for a
bishop captures on h3 we will swap off
rooks with rush of characters on b7
Bishop captures an f1 and now not going
for the roof right away but first Queen
captures an f1 as the rook is not going
anywhere you can always capture it on
the next move so tonight the d7 trying
to get rook to b8 and of course now he
captures it we have Bishop captures
Queen captures and now Queen to g2 the
material on the board is equal and white
fields that since black has a stronger
center and his Kings position is a bit
open that he should be be better off if
the Queen's get traded off and he is
correct so black declines this he goes
Queen to d8 black prefers to keep the
Queen's on the board
and now d3 preparing to develop the dark
square bishop here so f5 and it's not
all that easy for white to develop the
dark square bishop so here box box tries
f4 of course he wants characters and
captures so his bishop gets developed to
an active square however here we have a
very interesting movie for and the point
is and basically why I've chosen this
game as it's a very very instructive for
beginners this occurrence that happens D
captures on e4 and here F captures on e4
and now there is a better move than just
recapturing would have characters on
here and I believe forsen was going for
this however our force and was going for
this and only after captures he was then
planning to move the pawn to d3
however d3 right away I should just win
the game for black as it's checked
and you lose the night here however he
played instead after D captures and he
for he played F captures on e4 and this
is something that happens a lot in
beginners games something I believe the
term is a Auto capture like if you hear
a capturing sound or if you're playing
over the board and someone captures your
piece you automatically recapture you
wanna regain material balance however
most more often than not there's like an
in-between move and I solutions which
you could go for so here instead of
automatically recapturing there is the
d3 that just wins the game and okay
force and recaptured right away and now
a point is the same if Queen captures d3
does go for the check and threatens
night however the queen will then be
well we could basically show it just
captures d3 check and now you could go
for just blocking this with with the
knight or you could go for Bishop to e3
which challenges the bishop however it's
still possible however here after F
captors on e4 we have King to f1 voxbox
figures out that the d3 is a pretty big
threat so he gets his King out of the
way so Knight to f6 now the night is now
coming to g4 from there to e3 and so on
it will be a very dangerous piece and
both work still needs a way to develop
his LightSquared bishop so he goes b3 he
wants the eye maybe develop it through
this diagonal and now d3 force and now
pushes his deep on and it does create a
passport so captures captures it the
past deep on has been created and it's
an extremely strong pass pawn so Knight
to c3 and now that the night is on c3
undefended he goes for Bishop to d4 just
attacks it so he forces white to defend
it we have Bishop to b2 Bishop to e2
might be a bit more precise as you also
block the D pawn which could be very
important but okay Bishop to b2 they're
just blocking and now Knight to g4 and
now you can I'm pretty sure you can feel
that blacks position is really
overwhelming there's not all that much
or what can do here and this is uh well
this is just a wonderful wonderful path
to deep on so here
also there's just the threat of night -
III check which would pick up the Queen
so box box picks up on that and he goes
Queen to be to not allowing this to
happen and now there are a lot of moves
here you can play able to go Knight to
the III check Quinta a8 is a nice idea
going for Queen Queen to h1 also
possible but first Bishop to e3 force
and kicks away the Queen and he makes
room for his pawn to be pushed to d2 and
now we have Queen to D 1 and now another
thing that often happens in beginners
games you've attacked your opponent's
Queen he moved his queen but you don't
you don't often expect him to move the
Queen with with any deadly purpose with
with any reason you just expect that he
moved the Queen because you attacked it
and that's it and here he played d2
without realizing that by moving the
Queen the g4 Knight was under attack so
here he played d2 and in this position
this is pretty much the only move that
well after which your advantage slips
here you can do pretty much anything you
can defend the night and then just enjoy
your position then you can push b2 if
you want you can go with this idea queen
h2 h1 which will again be very dangerous
but d2 is a move that now gives Y to the
advantage as you blundered your knight
so here voxbox captures it and of course
I imagine he was very happy here and now
Queen to d3 check and okay the game's
not over a black still has a past D pawn
so Queen to e to the strongest move you
now of course want to trade and now you
cannot move the Queen away from the
defense of the bishop so what you could
do is do a counter attack here and after
do after this trade here white would
still be able to pick up the pawn for
example rook to the f king e2 and next
move you're just gonna pick up the pawn
so that doesn't work all that great in
blacks favor
so here force and decided to trade
Queens and hope for the best soap Queen
captures and e2 we have King capture
Sonny - and now rook to e8 threatening
some nasty discoveries so Albert moves
out of the way King to f3 and now King
to f7
bringing the bringing the King into the
game
we have Knight to d5 now putting
pressure on the best
you are up a piece of course you want to
trade down as much as possible and hear
a very interesting move Bishop to c5 and
now push up the c3 just going for that D
do pawn and here there is no good way to
actually defend your passed pawn here
you must part with it but force and
tries a last-resort sneaky tactic he
goes Bishop to d4 and the idea is now of
course if the pony's captured you
blunder your rook in a one box box did
not wander it he went for the bishop but
also we have to ask ourselves what's the
point of the bishop sacrifice the point
is after box box capture that force and
went rook to e1 and now the rook is
under attack and there are a lot of
threats here for example if you captured
the rook
obviously you get a queen into the game
if you don't capture the rook if you
play something let's say we're let's say
play Bishop to e3 you want to pick up
the pawn then it's just luke captures an
a1 and well there's not much you can do
here you can now capture the pawn but
you've lost the rook and it's it's a
rock against a bishop and nightwear
white could be slightly better so this
is this this rook to e1 is really a nice
idea the bishop sacrifice I mean other
than that you don't really have a lot to
go on
however there is a move that Ridge white
of all of his problems so feel free to
pause the video and try to find it the
best winning move for box box while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations and preventing both
threats threat number one being the rook
on a 1 is hanging and threat number 2
being the d1 queening square needs to be
protected and there one there is one
move that fixes all of that so for those
of you who just wanna enjoy a show it's
nice that III and now your rook is
defended and also the queening square is
defended so there is nothing more to
worry about
box box play that and now okay recap for
Sunday one was played but now we have
the shop character Sunday 1 and now
black the white is just up to pieces and
black will very quickly lose this
passport so did it continued the game of
course you can always achieve a
stalemate or your own
can blunder it does happen kingi tomb we
have h6 in our King capture sandy - so
the fast bone was eliminated and now g6
but now the two pieces are too strong
and you can see that Albert uses them
well preventing the King from even
crossing the to the other half of the
board we have a six not allowing the
point to be captured and now a four we
have King to d6 and now before preparing
to create a passed pawn king to c6 and
now g4 also there can be a passed pawn
created here we have King back to d6
and now Bishop to g7 forcing h5 so this
is what's played captures captures now
black does have a passed pawn however
white still has two pieces so f5
continuing to push the passed pawn and
now h4 with f6 and now King to e6
preventing the point from reaching f7
King to c3 and now h3 we have Knight to
g4 and now guarding the h2 square King
to f7 and we have came to c4 and now
King to g6 and now of course came to c5
although you could just push and create
a passed pawn I guess I guess Albert
wants to get rid of this guy the good
old fashioned way so King a5 and now
Knight to H do saving the knight King a
4 and now even f7 as now you've
abandoned your defense of the f7 pawn
king g3 and now f8 bring you a queen
into the game King captures on h2 but
now Queen a forecheck and now of course
a king hunt begins King G - we have
Bishop the d4 hoping to hoping to
deliver a quick quick checkmate with
check and mate so h2 and now Queen to f2
with check of course you go King to h3
hoping to get your Queen intro game and
now we have Queen to f1 with check King
to g3 and now Bishop e5 check kicks away
the king from the defense of the h2
point so King g4 and now Albert Albert
eliminates the h2 point as well
a5 and the sorry a five by black and now
be characters on a5 and now black got
rid of all of his material so he's still
hoping for a stalemate and voxbox needs
to well make sure that that doesn't
happen
so king h5 with a six Albert in order to
ensure that a stalemate doesn't happen
he will go for another queen so King g6
with a7 king to h7 in mount a 8 Queen
Albert now has two queens came to g7 and
now Queen F to F 8 the King Khan the
king hunt resumes so King g6 Quinta c6
with checking h7 and now Queen Sita h6
is a nice checkmate and this is how game
1 ended by Albert winning and forsen was
really playing a very impressive game he
did everything right he was better for
the entire game and then that move that
the the auto the auto capture isn't
really it wasn't really a problem here
this is something that happens to to a
lot of people for example missing this
the three idea however this is something
that also happens and this is where the
problem was after Queen to d1 our
Forsman just thought that box box was
completely helpless that Queen moved
really without any any reason however
the knight was under attack and then he
assumed control and he was better for
the rest of the game so that's one game
of their match from the quarterfinals
second game was one fairly quickly by
force and so he equalized the match and
then the match went into tie breaks and
the tiebreak match was won again by box
box who went for the exact same line of
the vienna and he was victorious so he
he wins the match and he goes to the
semi-finals and i don't know if i will
be covering any more games from the
quarterfinals but you'll see once we
reach the semi-finals the how the how
the intensity and the quality of the
games will drastically improve as well
then we already reach 1300 1400 player
1600 players and it already like this
was without that miss after queen to be
won this was a very instructive game
that black played oh yeah that's
basically the game I'd hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Christopher
Clark in my no Alfonso
John Tyler still Matthew Alden and
Tobias Kepler for a contribution to my
channel and thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my preview
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the pork champs checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day